would you like to hear a joke today why
do cows have hooves
because they lack toes man how come
ridley scott always has to do some weird
pregnancy thing
okay so the finale of raised by wolves
is just dropped on hbo max
and you probably have a ton of questions
throughout this video we're going to be
trying our best to answer everything
whilst also giving our theories on what
exactly is going on
obviously there will be heavy spoilers
here so if you haven't had a chance to
check out the finale yet then i highly
recommend that you check out now
please drop a thumbs up if you've been
enjoying our coverage so far
and don't forget to subscribe to the
channel for breakdowns on all your
favorite tv shows and movies
without the way this is the heavy
spoiler show i'm your host paul
now let's get into the breakdown okay so
episode 10 picks up with marcus
waking up after being ousted from the
mithraic last week
judo lucius stuffing one of mother's
eyes into his mouth his skin has been
badly burned by the microwaves
and he very much stumbles across the
planet looking for other signs of life
at one point the character bumps into a
vision of hunter who seemingly has a
snake for his arm
and snakes become almost central to this
entry
from the off the show was very much
laced with biblical references
and here they become far more prevalent
in the first episode we theorized how
mother and father were a metaphor for
adam and eve
and we see that come full circle here
with a snake leading them
out of their quote-unquote god of eden
both were pretty much the first man and
woman of this new paradise
and they wish to start a new
civilization but this snake destroyed
that notion
and thus they are cast out of their home
now though we never actually get it
confirmed
i believe that snakes are really the
ones that have been feeding visions to
both mother and the humans
marcus comes across a giant snake skull
head and he hears rattling upon touching
it
it was also inside the body of a snake
skeleton that he started to first
receive visions
and at the end of the season the snakes
are probably the only ones that come out
winning
kepler 22b was pretty much chosen to
house humanity
because of its similarity to earth and
it could be possible that the planet
goes far beyond that in many ways
had the dinosaurs not been wiped out by
a meteorite
it is possible that reptiles would have
remained as the dominant species on our
planet
evolving over time to become some
supreme snake overlords
yes i do watch rick and morty now these
snakes go
far beyond the ones that exist on our
planet and they are clearly intelligent
as they were able to seek out mother and
place a baby within her so that it could
grow
we also see that they have the ability
to fly and it is likely that they're far
evolved beyond the ones that live on our
planet now if kepler-22b
did mirror earth beyond this then it
also explains why there are humanoid
life forms on the planet
apes would have risen alongside the
snakes this time and they too
would have reached a certain point this
is why mother likely finds a skull of
one
and why she and father both remark on it
being neanderthal-like
they state that they've begun to devolve
but from a biological standpoint
there is actually no such thing as
devolution
everything evolves and grows typically
because of natural selection
and this could hint to how life was on
the planet if my theory is correct
then humanoid creatures evolved to a
certain point in which they had complex
brains
much like our own however the snakes
were able to infect these with wild
visions
that slowly sent the inhabitants mad
thus
the only ones that survived were the
less intelligent of the species
that were less susceptible to these
visions slowly
these idiots bit harsh but that's what
i'll call them
they became more and more prevalent and
the species
seemed to devolve purely for their own
survival as the snakes no longer really
had a food source because of this
they died out too and this is why we've
seen their great skeletons littering the
planet
on top of this though there is also the
potential that humans have visited
the planet before and this is why mother
finds a helmet with a skull inside of it
i actually watched prometheus yesterday
in preparation for this finale
and i have to say that the engineer
helmets look almost identical to this
there's even a scene where we have a
severed helmet with a head inside it
that i think massively echoes the
iconography that we get here
ridley scott was of course tied to both
projects and though fox own aliens and
warner brothers own this
i think he's purposely placing these
little easter eggs so that fans can
connect the dots
even if that isn't the case though
there's still a lot that this could
signify
now within the the conspiracy theory i
don't i don't know if that's the right
term but
within the the theoretical history
community there does exist a branch that
believes there was a civilization
that existed millennia ago which
advanced far beyond the technology that
we even have today
there's several cave paintings that
supposedly document this
and even in the cathedral of salamanca
there exists a carving of what appears
to be an astronaut
this sculpture was actually added quite
recently but
it has been used by many to theorize the
idea of ancient astronauts
now the show could be actually playing
into this too and perhaps a sect of
humanity left earth millennia ago
and landed on kepler-22b which is where
they created a settlement
they then fell victim to the snakes and
started to devolve
but we do see the relics of their past
such as the pentagonal objects and so on
again i'm just theorizing all of this
but scott has
dabbled in the idea of ancient
astronauts before so he could once more
be doing the same thing here
i don't want to just do my usual summary
of the episode as there's so much to
talk about
but the basic plot of the entry is that
mother father
and the humans seek out a place in which
mother can give birth
father discovers that mother had sex
with her creator champion
and he becomes jealous over this now i
absolutely love how both mother and
father over the season
have slowly started to become more and
more human and the actors behind the
characters do an
excellent job of nailing the
complexities of human emotions
creeping in whilst also portraying
things in a very robotic way
eventually mother gives birth and it's
revealed to be a snake
which has infected her my jaw was
literally on the floor over this reveal
and i'd be surprised if anyone actually
managed to predict this
because it's so left field i don't want
to bring up prometheus again too much
but
there's actually a scene in that where a
snake-like creature crawls into a
character's mouth
and this felt like the reverse of that
almost playing with the chess burster
motif from the alien
franchise but when did this pregnancy
actually happen
well i believe that the snakes infected
mother with visions
and these led to her going to the
hibernation pod which is where she
plugged herself in
they tempted her with the idea of being
reunited with the man that she loved
and thus this further echoes the garden
of eden metaphors
with a snake tempting the first woman in
order to gain something for itself
i believe the snakes also infected paul
with visions which furthered his
indoctrination into the mithraic
religion
and this is why he says he wants to give
his pet mouse to the child
i'm sure you already know but white mice
are used as a popular food source for
snakes
and watching this episode a second time
you pick up on just how creepy it is
that he wants to give it to the baby
now in a cave he finds almost prophetic
paintings
which show a giant snake and two
travelers in a ship
this comes to fruition at the end of the
episode with mother
father and the snake flying through a
tunnel to the other side of the planet
hey we did say last time these might be
used to get from point to point
and this episode definitely didn't
disappoint
crap puns as per now paul also informs
sue that seoul has
been telling him things and this
involves taking the flight key from the
land air
through the snakes he also discovers
that sue is in fact mary
and that she and marcus are not his true
parents this leads to poor shooting hair
i think it pretty much removes the
possibility of him being the chosen one
the show has done a terrific job of
keeping us guessing who the identity of
the true one is
and throughout these breakdowns we've
jumped from paul to campion to marcus
to the unborn baby and more however the
show
seems to settle on campion being the
chosen one in the end
but who knows if that will even last
beyond the next episode of season 2
which yes i'm very glad it's been
renewed
now mother actually kills the mysterious
hooded figure because it attempts to
attack her
in hindsight we know that it was likely
aware that she was carrying a snake
so it does make sense why it did this we
also get the reveal
and were right with our theory last week
that this would be one of the
inhabitants of the planet
but i'm still scratching my head over
what's going on
he does look almost reptilian so it is
possible that they even evolved from the
snakes themselves
but either way father says that they're
ignorant to the planet's history
so he likely ties back to the power
struggle on kepler that we theorized
over earlier
after the snake attaches itself to
mother she and father travel to the
other side of the planet
in order to try and kill it they
abandoned the lander on the opposite
side of kepler
but the snake escapes and will likely
become the apex predator
now hunting the humans it's terrifying
seeing this beast burst out of the craft
and it likely spells doom for the humans
especially because mother
no longer has her eyes what's worse than
a giant snake
a giant snake that flies now to make
matters worse
it now has a new food source and we
follow marcus as he discovers a group of
atheists that have made it to the planet
it makes sense that they too would
attempt to escape earth and they now
have an
advantage over the methodic as they
still have a ship that works
now whilst this could set up a new war
on kepler
i actually disagree that this will be
the case i think that humanity will
unite over this common enemy and try and
take down the snakes
if 2020 has shown us anything it's that
humans can
can all get on the same page about
something when we need to
it hasn't really however this is a tv
show
and i do believe that they will join
forces for the next season with us
getting a far more horrific series
that will hopefully play a lot more into
scott's man versus monster aesthetic
campion has now been chosen as their
leader and he has a long road ahead of
him
that will involve not only trying to
unite humanity but also stop this new
threat
i thought the finale was brilliant and
though i did find this season
a bit hit and miss from time to time
purely down to its pacing
it sets so much up here that i'm
extremely excited to see what happens
next
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
and theories so make sure you comment
below and let me know
there's going to be a ton of things to
talk about and i definitely want to see
your input
so yeah make sure you drop it in the
comments please
now if you enjoyed this video then
please drop a thumbs up and make sure
you check out our breakdown of the other
episodes in the series which are going
to be linked at the end
if you want to support the channel and
get to see content early then please
consider clicking the join button below
you can also come shadows on the discord
server linked in the description
or heavy spoilers on twitter thanks for
making it until the end of the video
you've been the best i've been
definition i'll see you next time take
care
peace
you